dans le rétroviseur de l'autobus
caquistes les gains de québec solidaire
sont plus proches qu'il ne paraisse
c'est ce qu'a prétendu gabriel
nadeau-dubois samedi soir avant
rassemblement sherbrooke où la course
s'annonce serré la campagne au québec
est de plus en plus nette à 2 je suis
d'accord avec lui qu'il ya deux visions
s'affrontent
une vision qui est plus réaliste qui
tient compte des préoccupations des
québécois une vision ben
tu penses que l'argent pousse d'un arbre
je lui aussi niort régulièrement les
autres partis pour concentrer ses
attaques envers québec solidaire les
exemples sont nombreux je pense
important que les québécois soient
informés de ces taxes orange il veut
même ajouté des taxes arrange la taxe
orange l'expression qu'il répète se
retrouve même sur un tract distribué par
les jeunes caquistes sur les pare-brise
des autos de montréal
québec solidaire a comparé cette méthode
avec seul employé jadis par les
conservateurs de stephen harper contre
leurs adversaires moi ce que je constate
c'est que françois legault passe de plus
en plus de temps à critiquer québec
solidaire est de moins en moins de temps
à parler de son projet de société
gabriel nadeau-dubois pour un jeune
politicien fait pas mal de vieilles
politiques une lutte à deux absolument
pas rétorque que les autres monsieur
nadeau dubois
devrait regarder réalité à l'extérieur
du plateau mont royal ils veulent un
portrait un peu différent je trouve que
ça peu de considération pour les
citoyens peu de considération pour la
démocratie lnd parti
québec solidaire et la coalition avenir
québec affirment tous les deux offrir
une nouvelle vision aux québécois mais
leur stratégie politique aujourd'hui ne
date pas d'hier en se désignant l'un et
l'autre comme adversaire l'objectif
c'est aussi d'isoler les autres partis
susceptibles d'attirer leur électorat
ici véronique prince radio-canada à
lotbinière